all right we are here Black Friday I
have a special edition today with uh the
man the myth the legend Harley who is
president of shopy we're going to go
over five to seven stores that are
absolutely crushing it now here's the
advantage that Harley has and that we
can share that no one else can he knows
what's going on in every single store
across the world in Shopify so he knows
who's killing it by how much and what
they're doing and then we're going to
highlight some of the things that
they're doing specifically well so that
you can either buying us to your you
know Shopify if you're if you have a
Shopify store or just how you how you
sell whatever it is that you sell we're
we're effectively turning on the camera
for conversations and you I usually have
private right like over text or F calls
or whatever I'm like hey check this out
this is really cool and so now we're
just going to kind of like open up the
Kona for it before we do that we you
check this out yeah let's go so we so
Black Friday sat Monday weekend uh is
sort of Super Bowl we have millions of
sources on Shopify and so what we want
to do is is project in real time
literally like minute to a minute how
things are going and uh we I think we
hit Peak a little earlier today brand
new EST on Friday but we're now at a 3.4
75 million doll in sales every single
minute minute every single minute 28,000
orders per minute and almost 30,000
unique Shoppers what is amazing though
okay so we're about to North America is
about to come here can I stand up yeah
so what you're about to see is this
North America right here so you see
where the orders originating from where
it's going to but there you may also
there these little fireworks oh okay so
those fireworks every one of those
fireworks is a brand new entrepreneur
getting their very first sale that is a
brand new entrepreneur being created the
common threat of what we're going to
we're going to talk about today is that
they're doing things that I think are
unobvious incredibly effective well
let's kick this off with gym shark I was
just texting null before this like hey
is there anything uh that n is is is the
best I think with gym shark because
obviously we're going to look at the
site we're about to break all like the
little details down but there's also the
things that they do prior to getting
into the site right which is what is the
brand what is the brand context that
this sits within and so I think Jim
shark does such a good job of building
the brand and giving and providing value
and making positive associations with
the right people the right athletes at
the right time um that when they give
when they need to give and they did like
Reps for mental health like they give
when they need to give but when it's
time to ask they ask if they mean it and
so Black Friday is the best time to ask
and so let's dive into it they also know
Their audience really really well so
remember there's a couple things let's
start high level and we'll go into
actual Tac High Jim shark is the
quintessential online retailer started
online Ben Francis starts this he's
literally a pizza delivery guy in 2012
starts jym shark and they build this
amazing online business it's an online
brand
phenomenally but actually right now one
of the most interesting things about
them is they have a massive physical
store popup in New York city so they are
not necessarily staying within the
confines of one particular Channel
they're expanding well beyond that as
well this offline presence is going well
now now they will still do the majority
of their sales I suspect they haven't
told me this I suspect will be online it
doesn't matter this idea of having a
12we popup for the holidays is amazing
that's one second is it's a 12we holiday
popup right it's not four days it's 12
weeks and so the fact that they're doing
a three-month popup about holidays means
not only are they starting before their
comp competition they're also ending
after their competition yeah right so
they're expanding that that's something
that's really cool they did this really
cool social media Campaign which was
sort of
like quote there will be signs and no
one knew what their will be signs meant
well what it meant was in all their
advertising there would actually be
Easter XG these little of what they were
doing now it wasn't obvious it was super
unobvious but because Jim shark is so
creative and their community and fans
are so creative their fans kind of
understood something there so people
started going doing a deep dive into
every marketing campaign every new
product so they actually convinced
people to spend more time on the site to
look at look at what is actually doing
It's Kind like the super when people are
like oh I just want to watch the ads
it's like they're actually they're
getting their whole audience the most
engaged audience to pay attention to it
but not only that but also make content
about their marketing that's exactly
right which then gives them this whole
extra you know lift to uh their their
Impressions and so I I thought that was
really really cool so a couple things so
I'm just put that what is is Easter eggs
a lot of Easter eggs they did really
really well all right cool so let's
start with the uh let's start with the
site so what's the what's the if if
we're talking pure conv look like look
at like this site is a effectively a
giant coupon yeah now one of the little
this is me getting
s ttic so if we look here there's a
couple things that I I want to point out
to to to my folks which is number one is
they talk about lowest prices on top
sellers which is nice because number one
it's like okay we're not just doing it
on the crap we're doing it on the good
stuff all right so it's point one number
two is now this is a little bit of um
again this is just tactics notice that
it's with the code and so I know this
sounds like a small thing but sometimes
basically getting people to I think you
maintain the retail value from a brand
perception perspective and then only at
the checkout people then realize the
savings and I think it I think it feels
different as as it's closer to the
purchase now that I don't have a a
double blind Placebo split test to back
it up that's just me as a well actually
what I would suggest though is that in
this particular case they're being
incredi like they're giving it to you in
a silver platter they're saying
effectively go by right now now
traditionally if you look at this site
in 3 weeks from now it's very slick oh
yeah black incredible imagery great
product photography this is different I
don't know what like this is a
completely different thing that you've
never seen before I also want to point
something out also look at the order on
top there's only three things in the top
header yeah women's sale men's sale
accessory sale they don't have any of
their other product categories this is
deliberately designed for this
particular week so if we're thinking
about when you're when you're making
offers for whatever it is that you're
selling it's it's it's narrowing focuses
right or F fol folks ey right so we've
seen that yeah
F the um so they did this experiment
there's 24 jars of gem and then six jars
of gem at the Super Market and they had
people try them out and the 24 jars of
gy had more people try them but less
people buy and then the six got way more
buyers like two or three times more
buyers and so the same thing happens is
that we have to focus as entrepreneurs
and say okay I'm going to have a
disproportion amount of attention my
customers are going to have their
wallets out at this moment what am I
going to prioritize yeah yeah and it's a
parox of choice yeah give people too
much choice and they're going to get
lost so this I think is very very
effective because they are they are
giving you breadcrumbs leading you
exactly to where they want you to go I'm
say focused
product Suite is another one and I'll
add in the uh the
conversion conversion
coupon uh emphasis all right so there is
one other thing that before we move on
from them that I I thought was
interesting so I was curious about why
would they do a longer popup and one of
the things that I think they did didn't
tell me this but I is at the early stage
of their popup again this was a holiday
popup that was three months in in in in
duration is I believe they figured out
very quickly what was going to be the
hottest items for the action season so
they pretested again this is only my
hypothesis they're very smart I think
the fact that they were able to get in
in in October 1st they knew what was
going to sell at the end of November no
one else was able to do that I think
that type of I don't know like like
crystal ball yeah I think I like I think
that is very effective and I'm certain
that's in some marketing meeting or some
meeting at that company or even in other
companies they said why would gy to a
three- Monon popup for the holidays and
I think they were thinking themselves
we're g to get so much data soer so
what's your later this is such a so all
businesses I like this big
generalization but like data is so
powerful when it comes to weaponizing
resources right and so for us for
example like I'll just completely
different perspective but like the
content that we know performs the best
tends to be when we look at past content
that has done well and then we combine
just winners and so it's like we create
you know 450 pie of content a week but
we only make one or two Longs and the
Longs do really well but it's because we
have 438 shots on goal that we say okay
we're just going to take the top 20 of
the you don't have to make any
assumptions right you can see right away
we know this before that's exactly right
awesome those are some of the things I
think for Jim shark that that work
really well all right rock and roll
let's let's move on to uh let's actually
let's go to let's go to let's go to the
let's go to bark Buck you have it up
here let's rock it okay okay box okay
Bark Box if you have a pet you likely
know you want to move this I'm going to
this guy we'll recap at go all right
Bark Box this is like a you know an Alex
size posted note this how I good um okay
so BarkBox if you don't know it is this
incredible Pet Food business pet company
um and one of the things that I think
they do really really well is that they
have a deep understanding of their
customer not just disimilar from gym
shark but one of the things they did was
they actually
created challenges to get discounts so
rather than simply give up the discount
they created these pet quizzes they've
been doing this for a couple weeks now
but it also it created this interactive
gameification it wasn't simply here's a
coupon go buy it and they have
competition I mean there's a lot of
shoes that there's a lot of other
companies out there but I think one of
the reason that bbx is winning is
because it doesn't feel like a simp a
simple transaction it feels like you're
actually doing something a lot different
it's like customer it's like
and you're also challenging people to
say like if you do this and you do it
well you get this reward right it's
almost pav yeah and and I
think um so I just I think they did it
really well I also think thing they did
is they created um a very personalized
experience because one of the things
they got from the quiz they got a lot of
great information about the customer
notice common theme on the data here
side not yes oh yeah exactly I mean all
these people are yeah they're retailers
I guess primarily but they're incredibly
smart um business innovators they look
at data there they're they're scientific
about how they run these promotions and
so here's a great idea because they did
this challenge based coupon so you got
this gamification piece of it but you
also they were able to ingest a ton of
data from their customers so now you
know like I I didn't take the quiz but I
assume one of the quiz questions was
name of your pet um tell me about the
age of your pet now you actually have a
wonderful datab they know they're
remarketing what they're going to be
precisely now you have this wonderful
database breed right sure um but I think
this idea that like the best
entrepreneurs play into the brand the
strength of their brand they're not
trying to be at some point we're going
to talk about butcher box not be box you
make that mistake it may be awkward um
but they're not trying to be like a
high-end Meat Company they're just
trying to be who they are and I think
they have a really good understanding of
that um so lowkey personalized
experience that was delivered through
this gamification I think they did
really well and Mar box is been
phenomenal and I'll talk about uh one
one really big one so on jym shark I
didn't mention it but it was there they
had a top banner and so one of the one
of the best and most valuable pieces of
real estate on on any online story is
going to be the top banner I think when
I was scrolling this guy there it is yep
so you can see they have their top
banner and they're they're making like
that is especially on mobile which you
probably know the percentage of traffic
but a huge percentage of traffic more
than right now across the internet more
for online retail more than half the
traffic is on mobile historically the
actual check out was lower that's
changed with things like shot pay ah
like shopay I'm not not this isn't a
shop pitch it's true because even though
you may browse on a mobile device you
didn't want to have to put in your
credit card number on a mobile device
annoying but now it's we're to Checker
whether it's chop or or appay makes much
easier so conversions have gone
dramatically up on a mobile device
because of acceler J which is great
because that's where a lot of
impressions are served precisely so uh
BarkBox also has this but I want to
double click into not actually double
click but like let's zoom into uh the
they wanted to make it easy for
firsttime buyers and so they're going
you know obviously they have all this
marketing theyve all these people are
sharing stuff and get your first box for
$7 right so they know obviously they're
going to they're going to do things for
their repeat customers they're going to
take care of their existing audience but
you have this opportunity where you have
a disproportionate amount of eyeballs
with new customers and so if you can
double down and make a crazy offer
because you know what your LTV is on
that customer it's a great time to do it
now when paired with and this is again
we're going to mix and match here but
with gy shar's iners emphasis it's like
you can get this deep relationship now
they're approximating that by getting
tons of information on them but in the
IRL setting so in real life you also get
the this test for in a clothing store
right and they're like wow and it it
becomes a totally different shopping
experience it becomes an identity shift
you say you know I'm a gym shark fan I'm
a gym shark athlete whatever and look
products that are on there they are
their top I don't know I I can't really
see if there's light there I those are
top four selling products likely right
they're just making it all the here's
what we sell do you want these things
you can buy them right now we have so
first-time buyer incentives uh and they
did the same thing as as uh Jim shark
which is prioritize the buy box right
they know what people want and they're
making sure that it's clear and evident
uh and it's look it's timely what look
what the banner says bark Friday that
web this page is created for today it is
Black Friday it is not it is not like
the weekend or holiday special this is a
deal for right now in hyper real time
and if you don't get it by midnight yep
you know as I say in French safey need
yeah safing makes
so but yeah so Banner urgency and
firsttime offer prioritizing the best
products using data to it to create
deeper relationships for remarketing the
future people are going to have lower
action thresholds uh now so they're
going to it's easier to get people to
take that first step and give you a
little bit more information we' did
something like that this morning as well
which is like okay we're going to make
this big for acquisition. comom uh we
have our scaling road map that came out
but people had to fill out all this
information for their business now
obviously that's going to help tailor
the thing that we're going to give them
but it also helps you it's going to be
useful for meix and actually that's a
great quit proo cow because most people
don't want to give information for free
but if I can give you information and
return for that information you're going
to give me a discount you're going to
give me money back person that's right
and also bottom left corner of the
screen this is what they want they want
you to Bas up for their subscription
yeah right so they like it like yes you
can buy things alak cart are up there as
well but it's ultimately they want a
multi-on subscription from you and
they're giving you an incentive to do it
on bark Friday now also to to to bark
back to Har back to Harley's Point
earlier notice the top we've got there's
only three three or four things that
that they had there and I'm sure that um
their site probably has a more in-depth
navigation uh course I mean we this is
the trend we're seeing right now right
these sites are built for today yeah
built for today I mean when you have
when you when you that sounds cheesy but
I mean like literally built for Black
Friday yeah because you you might be
able to do a month like think about the
amount of work that you do for a month
if you can do that amount of sales in 3
days then you should allocate the same
amount of re basically you should
respect that time as an additional month
of year yeah yeah all right so look like
you know 12 hours ago Shopify you know
if you looked at that counter when it
first came live Thursday night it was
about $800,000 a minute now it's $35
million a minute like this isn't just
some random thing this is the day the
consumers are purchasing and these
people have begin to prare how many
minutes would we going rough 10 15 I was
going to do the simple math just to say
while we've been on there's been
probably another 50 million in sales
that we we got we got a lot to cover
here yeah let's do it let's uh let's go
to QVC back because this is not
unobvious when I told you I was going to
talk about QBC you told me you're like
are you sure I was like yes trust me on
this one and I was like save it for the
live because everything you started
getting into was like everyone's gonna
want to hear this so if you remember if
you like me you remember QVC is like
what your mom was watching on TV for
like the 17th pair of fake jewelry uh
that's not fake it's a stone from Africa
that was mined in you know whatever
right uh and so this is a totally
different QVC from what uh I grew up
with and probably you grew up with and
so yeah Harley take it away okay so QVC
the the the way that it used to work is
actually
very very it used to it was it's a very
simple process you had it was a channel
that ran like basically indefinitely it
was like always on and they had these
people coming and presenting these
beautiful things check out this if you
want this call us now then it evolved
and it became if you want this go to
this particular web page so actually QVC
came to Shopify and they said we
actually want to build video on demand
they wanted to build something where
concurrently with the actual ad the
video you can actually purchase right
then and there like oneclick checkout
and so the way it works is you actually
see these product thumbnails show up in
the video on demand and it's under like
the the hottest holiday host gift
Channel um but the thumbnail link over
it's guilt on hydrogen which is Shopify
is headless product and you can actually
check out while you're watching the
video the reason this is interesting is
because there are way too many ads
videos out there where you effectively
have to leave the video to go make the
purchase meet people where they are if
they're watching the video make allow
them to continue to watch the video
Don't Stop the flow of information don't
stop the entertainment value because
that's not what they want there's a very
high likely of chance if you if you get
them to leave the video and go into a
checkup like a four page checkup or even
a onepage checkup yeah too much friction
and so the fact that QVC which is I
don't know how how long they've been
around someone can probably figure that
out but they've been around for many
many decades the fact that they've
created a seamless like concurrent
shopping experience tells me that even
older companies are able to innovate and
use technology some really cool stuff
and I would bet dollars to Donuts that
the people who buy once are more likely
to buy a second time while they continue
to tune in and so it's like we don't
want to break this moment so we talk
about this in our stuff like we have
hyper buying Cycles like there are these
moments where buyers will enter so like
let's say you you decide you want to
start doing a Turkey Trot or you want to
do some 5K or whatever well as soon as
you make that decision all of a sudden
you're like well I want I want new shoes
and I want some shorts and I want one of
those iPod you know armbands yeah and so
if you if you immediately sell the
shorts and then they have to leave they
are they might forget about that and
then they'll remember again but with a
different retailer and so it's like when
they're in that window a lot of a lot of
business owners are afraid to like kind
of lean in it's like that's when the
when the when the iron is hot strike
whatever the saying is um yeah go the
other thing I was goingon to say is you
know when I was last when I was on your
your your your podcast you talked about
that you know a lot of people that you
you meet with sort of own more
traditional businesses gyms there is
this this I don't know this thing that I
hear a lot which is well this is the way
it's done right like I've inherited this
business where I bought this company and
this is how we do sales This Is How We
Do you know are we business I don't
believe like if QVC is able to innovate
entirely on the process there's no
reason that every one of you watching
that has a more traditional business is
not able to do so um and and I I just I
have to give credit credit credit is due
it's an amazing experience and the fact
that they came to Shopify which is not
it's not the traditional Shopify
Merchant um I I think is great so I like
the idea of reducing friction and common
themes here so boom we've got a a top
Banner for right now with the code same
thing look at say Black Friday right so
everybody knows they're in the right
place at the right time for them and I
will bet you again dollars to Donas that
those four boxes that are the first
thing that you see underneath those
those deals are probably the things that
they know are the things that that were
getting this this page has already been
optimized for conversion they know that
these items that they have in each of
these categories are the things that
people are wanting to buy right now and
look at the products right the products
are amazing products these are things
they want to buy right now they also
have this game Spin to Win but they like
I don't know just I like the fact that
it's it's a clean site it's very obvious
what they want to do and it doesn't look
like a 50-year-old company not at all
yeah the cool thing that QVC has is they
probably have more data during this
season than maybe like anyone and so
they know exactly what people want to
buy right now and they and so like also
for a smaller retailer or like any kind
of smaller business a lot of times we
like to think about things as David and
Goliath and we're going to talk about a
David and goath story in a minute but we
have this idea that like we want to like
beat the big guys one of the best things
you can do is look at what they're doing
like if they have a certain different
categories that are put up there it's
for a reason they've got a team of
people that did a ton of research for
six months and the cool thing is is that
you can use someone else's team in
research and basically take the
inferences and then still use them for
your business yep let's talk about the
David and K thing because there there is
one store BK Beauty do we have that
those up here can you pull pull up BK
Beauty there we go okay so um first of
all BK
Beauty um yeah look like you me yeah
uh so fairly simple in terms of the look
clean great imagery they you know they
give you their endorsements of of like
why you should buy from them very simple
you know value statements here but
here's what's really neat some of the
people that at BK Beauty they are
actually I think they're the top selling
like at all brands on Tik Tok shops
which which we power they are the top
selling shop bkb I'm not kidding it is
unbelievable and most people don't
haven't heard of them but here's the
thing about BK Beauty they are um
they're not glossier they're not Kylie
Cosmetics I know I know glossier and
Kylie well because they're on shop like
Fenty as well they're not like that
they're more of a a startup brand and so
when you talk about startups you often
end up in this like David versus Goliath
thing the thing that I think was so
genius about what they've done recently
is they said look there's Mass like the
Cosmetics industry is littered with
hedonic like you know uh incumbents big
companies out there instead of going
head-to-head with them they went
actually created Partnerships with them
so listen to this they created
Partnerships with
Maybelline L'Oreal and other major
Beauty Brands that were just getting
started on Tik Tok they went to them and
said look we actually know how to do Tik
Tok ads better than you do instead of us
competing with you why don't we do
collaboration and actually this idea of
David Goliath they said it's actually
going to be D David actually partners
with Goliath and it's amazing to see a
startup partner with these very large
Brands and uh and and they've done some
really cool stuff they've also native
migrations I said Tik Tok but they've
also used Shopify to Native integrate
into YouTube as well so right from a
YouTube cosmetic tutorial you're able to
buy BK Beauty but they just seem to be
doing things completely different um and
um and and and so speaking of the
different thing so I said that there one
of the biggest stores the biggest store
in Tik Tok shops they also do
traditional marketing usually you see
these merchants or these brands that do
one of the other they're either the
Insurgent or they the incumbent if
they're the Insurgent and social media
they're doing things that like you know
that the big companies can't or they're
they're incumbent in the nut traditional
marketing yeah BK Beauty you can find
them on Tik Tok and you can also find
them on The View for example right so
they actually they don't they have no um
specific biases towards different
marketing channels agnostic exactly show
me the return on ad spend what is the
RAS where can I get my CA to a
particular point that it makes sense for
me relative to my my lifetime value so
that's a company that I just think is
doing things completely different they
they haven't emulated anybody else and I
love the idea of collaboration versus
competition and um I'll just say as a as
a personal different side note on this
is that this direct native integration
so this is actually kind of a similar SC
to the uh the QVC uh story earlier but
um if you have the opportunity it's one
of those High leverage things that's
worth investing in which like I'll give
you a very a simple example like I have
uh on Twitter this little box that's
inter now I'm sorry Jesus yeah so on X
there's uh there's this little box it's
like a buy box for people of products
but for me I just made it a$ Z product
that then just goes to my email list and
so because it's so native to to the
platform it outperforms relative to my
view count compared to other platforms I
have because it's so native well same
with Tik to like Tik Tok really wants to
make Tik Tok shops a thing I don't know
how long that's going to last but if you
were early on that you did well same
thing with YouTube and Spotify when
Spotify wanted to get into the podcast
business those early podcasts generate a
lot of sales because you were actually a
your growth with some other company's
macro Mission or or you know objective
for that particular and they're and
they're flooding and so like the David
and goli thing is that if you're one of
those early uh podcasts it's like spot
you get to basically tap into their
resources and their distribution and
their kind of track record where they
get to tap into your Innovation your
adaptability and so uh a lot of these
big guys like real talk for all the the
smaller entrepreneurs here um you are a
dangerous player on the board
right because they know that given the
size of their infrastructure it's so
difficult for them to make big bets and
everyone's afraid of losing their job
and having the bad idea that a lot of
these bigger companies just kind of stay
relatively stagnant they just let's just
stick with the Playbook it's worked for
five years it's worked for 10 years
don't don't mess and the big companies
you know just to say it like they don't
have the found they don't have the
founder energy right you know I I've
often said and I Ben has heard me say
this on the gymstar at I was like I bet
you there has been some board meeting
where someone on the Nike board went up
to the the white board said some of our
you know major risks is jib shark yeah
um that is unbelievable that that a
10-year-old company is an exal threat to
a company like Nike but it's true these
you know a lot of the small businesses
that are that are watching you think
that the big companies like you're
worried about the big companies eating
your lunch they actually are way more
worried about you eating their lunch and
the reason is they have way more
resource they have way more Capital to
deployed and invested in their ads so if
you use creativity and they're using
capital and you beat them well you can
with a new idea they can't spend
unlimited amounts of money and you can
do things as a small business that they
can which is things that don't scale so
for example I I bought
this so my I I bought this this is um if
you really like coffee and you're not
price sensitive there's a coffee machine
called X blue okay X blue um and letter
X and blue and it's this beautiful you
know the pourover method for coffee do
you drink coffee uh probably not so I
drink coffee in the morning I have a
machine so the like the way to drink
coffee is like the Hipster Brooklyn
style T of right I don't have the
patience for it so X has actually
figured out how to actually do that what
I loved about it so I bought this coffee
machine I found it on on the shop app it
was really great but I got a hadn't
written note from the CEO from the B of
it and the note was like Hey Harley
thanks for buying it I love Shopify I
watch your have this podcast called Big
Shot he's like I like all these things
there is no way that any major Coffee
Company could have ever done that that
doesn't scale yeah so actually you know
the X was probably thinking about how
Breville is going to eat their lunch but
brille should be way more worried about
them because xlum can do things that
that don't scale and that's where you
can get those crazy BR at like basically
you can compensate for their lack of
capital by having Superior row I'm
talking about them right now yeah right
I'm talking that like it took them eight
minutes or or five minutes do some
research on me write that letter and now
I've told that story 10 times and
that'll probably sell 10 machines yeah
it is a great cment it is expensive um
okay let's keep going here because
there's a lot going on I want to talk
about one that is super
um which one we Burger King for let's do
Burger King okay so this is weird Burger
King Size up for Shopify um not our
typical Merchant by any means they also
don't sell a lot of like physical
product that would ship to you their
burger restaurant but they created this
thing it's called the most Whopper full
time of the year and it's a freaking
Advent calendar and I was like this
thing it's weird and and do you see it
there there you go yeah pull it up there
okay there it is there we go this thing
sells out
instantaneously okay um it was 12 items
ranging from figurines to Brandon
sunglasses um it started on November
22nd uh it was uh it cost $19 54 cents
they were created 1954 um and you had
$100 worth of of product in it um it was
unbelievable it sold it immediately the
reason this so interesting is
because McDonald's doesn't doing things
like none of the competition
like this but they were able to create
these things that actually are
Collectibles it's not for people that
like the burgers there it's for people
that like pop culture right and they
expanded their brand well beyond that
but it was this like the thing about
Advent calendars even though there's
oldest time is it's a it's a consistent
reminder but the brand and actually uh
Brew dog did one um vages did one fly by
Jing did one a lot of great Brands did
Advent calendars this year I haven't
seen Advent calendars come in in a long
time but the reason I think Advent
calendars actually could work if you
have the right type of product and brand
is because it's not a oneand done can
you toine admin yeah it's it's basically
uh it's it's a scheduled release okay so
you you you you buy it could be 30 days
in this case we're burking was 12 days
but it's it's effectively um something
you get um multiple times okay and it's
it could be delivered to you all in once
or you actually can get it every couple
of days for a period of time so you buy
it once now there's an element of
surprise there's an element of Discovery
and mystery about these ADV calor you
don't always know what you're getting um
and it worked really well one of them so
fly by Jing which is um sort of a sauce
company very popular sauce company um I
don't know if you can pull up fly by Jan
they're they're really fascinating um if
you can find it it's worthwhile just
while they pulled it up this is also the
same like Easter egg energy vibe from
gyar it's the same idea so look at this
and these cheap things this is their
Advent calendar it's beautiful but
here's the thing they're testing sauce
this year for
2025 this is entirely I mean it's a cool
product they made money with it but it's
also a test of what they should make
next year so one of their sauces I'm
going to pronounce this wrong but it's
not San but Sichuan sauce um was in this
and they wanted to know whether or not
their fan base was going to like this
and and the the presumption was use this
like have your your best sellers you
know as couple as a couple of these
releases but have a couple demos there
and see what the crowd thinks of the
demos and in fact this completely sold
out so this was sold out in 2024 and all
they did it strictly by email social
media and by text messaging and this is
a way for them to test things that
they're considering launching next year
and they're able to do it through the
Advent site and so one of the cool
things with this is you can drive huge
amounts of scarcity huge amounts of PR
around some crazy unscalable thing right
like fundamentally you don't know which
of these sauces are going to be good
hypothetically now every business has
their own sauce right their own products
there and whatever and so for them they
get to say okay well we don't want
everyone to try off because might suck
right and so but they get their hardcore
fans with lots of scarcity lots of
urgency tons of earned media that comes
as a result of that and then the the big
cookie for them is like not only do they
get all that stuff they get the data
that's right now let's go back for a
second to Burger King because the other
thing that Burger King did is Burger
King typically has their total adress
Market is it's large but it's fairly
shallow okay I think what they were able
to do with this particular calendar this
Advent calendar was they were able to
create a different relationship to the
brand very few Brands can possibly do
that a lot of the race car companies do
so you may drive a Porsche for example
there's a lot of wearing Porsche jackets
not not my style like that stuff but
that now they're able to like you only
you only may drive that car once and a
lot of people can't afford the Porsche
but a lot of people that cannot afford a
Porsche are walking around in Porche
merchandise right or Ferrari or Ferrari
Ferrari is probably even a greater
example of that so that's kind of what
Burger King did they're like look the
transaction is typically you buy a
burger or fries but now actually we're
going to create a limited edition
product that is going to be super cool
and I think that they created a new type
of relationship with an um an unobvious
um constituency of of their of their of
their brand and I I I'll I'll pck you
back on two other things I think burer
King did really well that we were
talking about before this um is that
they've been very Nimble and like
they're dare I say like becoming almost
cool they're almost cool well they're
like in fact their their tagline now is
forget the forget the clown McDonald's
go with the King and then they they did
this this massive uh I don't know if you
guys saw this but they did this National
deal where it was like you could get a a
Whopper if you were within 500t of the
McDonald's and located it yes yes and so
but they so this is how they got this
massive adoption of their app was but
it's like think about how many different
ways could I get adoption of an app it's
like but not only did they do it they
did it in a fun cheeky way uh so people
would drive to McDonald's to then buy
the the walk I always thought like uber
should do that with push notifications
at a particular hour um near bars like
near like sixth stade Austin Texas or
like you know in in downtown in Vegas or
something where you know someone is
around is is probably out at a club or a
bar they probably had a few drinks why
not just say would you like a car right
now push it as opposed to have them pull
it right and I I I think there's a lot
of opportunities or or you know um Uber
eat even can kind of do that hey it's
late night hungry you just got out of
the car yeah right we know you went from
the club District to your home you
probably want like a snack or something
like that when they get into the car
you're driving by the time you get home
can guarantee
that's where you sort of like forget the
this is actually I'll take a like we has
been public now for 10 years yeah um
we're about to celebrate our 10 year
anniversary May in May 2024
um this this will be sort of the May
2025 will be our 10 year anniversary we
un public May in May 2015 the we did
this road show where you meet all these
investors we did 93 meetings on the road
show I I absolutely loved it data
company public I think From aler
perspective is like one of the coolest
things I was able you know our team rang
devel to New York Stock Exchange it was
a very special moment but the number one
question we got when we were on the road
for Shopify was we like the company we
like the product but your Tam feels very
small your total j market and the reason
that that was an annoying question for
me or annoying point was they were sort
of looking at us taking a bigger piece
of the pie rather than growing the P
itself and at the time the pie was
retail smbs right if you think about
shop today a lot of people like that you
shop we have B2B business a lot of them
are not snbs anymore they weren't able
to properly predict what we were going
to sell to I think that's what a lot of
people do wrong they look at I own a gym
therefore the people that I'm going to
Target are going to be people that go to
other gyms and that's you taking a
bigger piece of existing pie instead of
thinking about like what if I Target a
people that have never been to the gym
before how do I grow the pie itself
that's how you build real billion dollar
companies I think so one of the really
interesting so it's obviously I'll jump
on the galy but one of the things that
we used to talk about is your biggest
competition is the couch and so G right
exactly it's the couch right and so one
of the really cool things is we like to
sell in a vacuum in every business you
have right because you don't want to
price compete you want to be able to
have your own unique message that's
going to resonate with specific audience
and so with when you when you create
your Market they don't you're you're
everyone's first love they don't know
they're not like well you know the other
guy down like of course you're going to
have some people who price shop but the
vast majority of people if you're kind
of activating going from 0 to one one
the market is a gazillion times bigger
and so um it yeah go ahead used to say I
I know read a little bit and he used to
say the Netflix biggest competition is
sleep kind like and I I think that's
sort of how you have to think about it
that your total deal market for what
you're selling is the same Tam as oxygen
it just doesn't matter of how do you
find your way into it and Burger King is
now like again are they going to change
their entire business no but they've
created this new way for customers to
engage with them and I think that's
really really cool let's go a butcher
boss let's do it
okay so um not to be confused with bark
Bo yes yes that's right
um also beautiful site yeah beautiful
photography um are you are you a
carnivore oh yeah okay so like so am I
like just my mouth is water just kind of
looking at this right it's just
spectacular so here's the thing so first
of all their Black Friday thing in
advance of of Thanksgiving was they want
to sell as many turkeys as possible okay
that was their thing they're like they
want to sell turkey now it's it's gone
now cuz was last night they've already
changed the site but if you would have
looked at this two days ago it would
have been all about turkeys but here's
what they did there is they acquired a
company called Truffle Shuffle okay
Truffle Shuffle is a really cool company
but it's it's it's live cooking classes
they acquired them and they did this
thing called go gobble paloa and it was
all these amazing cooking classes okay
they over delivered free information
like in an insane way not gimmicky not
social like sure like actual incredible
things here here you go um and and they
gave a this amazing class this class
could have been you ever seing like
those amazing documentaries on like
Netflix about like Chef's tabl it was so
beautifully done and there was only like
the logical step would be to have a call
to action for the class to go directly
to you know uh to the brand they didn't
do that they simply overd delivered and
didn't ask for anything in return
knowing that by creating more value than
than people expected they would come
back the next time and eventually to
your point they will say now it's time
like like you said about Jim shark
eventually they're going to say if you
want to actually do this with us next
time go buy your own ingredients and
here's where you buy it so here's what's
really so I love I I like anybody in my
world knows that I love this strategy a
ton right so one is they went after a
media asset first and so they're like
okay well we have a superior
monetization vehicle than you know this
this media company does right they can
sell sponsorships or whatever and the
thing is that when you when you buy into
a media I'm not going to super deep on
the m&a side but like whenever you buy
media their monetization mechanism is
sponsorships right so they run it's and
so basically if every one of your
competitors and maybe you're running ads
in a specific channel it's like well
wouldn't it be cool have I got those ads
for free yeah right it says fun what did
they basically bought all of the ad
space forever for one price yeah be the
content yes right and so obviously with
what we do we do the same I mean I love
the strategy is what I um that's why I
want to end with this yeah and so we're
so I saw a different company do this
really well
um it was actually Levis and so it was
so funny so I was uh I was I was looking
for a pair of jeans or something I can't
remember it was and they they said how
to how to dress this pair of jeans now
it's become a little bit more
commonplace but the first time I saw it
was years ago and they had one guy
basically wear this pair of jeans in
like six different settings and
basically when the video he like would
walk in and then it would like freeze
for a second so it would it would show
all the different things and then it
walked out and then another version with
the same jeans and so it very subtly
cross sold a ton of other things well
also say Okay jeans work for a lot
because I mean jeans are so like you've
got hipsters and jeans you've got
working men like it's such a broad
category so it's like how do you know
even because like even the way that they
put the model together is going to
automatically only convert a specific
type of the audience and so they showed
basically four or five different avatars
who you're like oh I don't resonate with
the Hipster but that one's mine right
they basically took a shopping cart and
added to their Tam right they're just
like they're going down the eye like Tam
Tam Tam I I love that stuff also I also
think what it does do it makes it
invites you in let's say you're not as
cool as a hipster but maybe you want to
be but you're but you you do you do
self-identify one of those other
characters you believe oh that's this is
for me right and I think that's I think
that's really great I also like the fact
that you do this well but what I loved
about butcher box is they didn't
actually ask for there was no call to
action to buy during the actual class
just check it out just check it out yeah
and I think that that is that is
remarkable because I don't think that is
how traditional marketing typically
worked and I think the best companies
you don't know that you're being sold to
and people want to buy they don't want
to be sold that's right and so I had so
I had I had a conversation with um Chris
Davis who's uh New Balance at CMO and so
we had a really good conversation the
other day you guys will you guys will
get access to it uh my notes from it and
one of the most amazing things they did
was he basically went all in on this
concept and so if you guys have seen the
big re you know boom of New Balance he
came in and said okay 70% of our
advertising budget is going towards
bottom of funnel so me meaning like
direct asks go buy shoes whatever right
and only 30% is dedicated to
storytelling kind of value creation
emotional kind of you know
identification for an audience whatever
and so what he did was he said let's
flip that and then for 18 months it
basically didn't pay off at all and then
at month 19 it just and then it just
started taking off like a rocket and
there's a couple of like I think
meaningful lessons from that it was
probably my it was probably my most
significant story that I heard this year
at least for me and so number one is
given the amount of spend that those
guys have it still took a year and a
half and so if you were and they're New
Balance right yeah they're like people
know who they are already and so I think
it's like the patience game of this is
so big especially when it comes to Brand
because I think one of the things that
uh obviously we broke down the sites we
should you know there's banners there's
specific coupons everybody optimized
their page for the day there was
specific urgency there was clear three
offers or four offers that they knew
they streamlined the top part this one
didn't have one it just has Banner um
but the stuff that's happening outside
of this is the stuff that really
dictates how well well this is going to
go right how much give has happened
prior to this ask um is almost directly
proportional to the amount of sales that
they're generating um can we put up the
the globe for a second because I want
there's one more thing I want to sort of
point out here which I think is
interesting so you know you're looking
at millions of stores it's great we're
about to go to North America when you
see these stores there's this often most
people have this assumption that those
are well that's Alo yoga and those are
like the big ones on to that's not those
are like millions of different stores
the one thing though that I think that
is remarkable now is if you sort of
think the consumer side of it my my big
takeaway from like Black Friday 2024 is
that consumers actually prefer to buy
direct with people that that they
believe are behind the product that this
idea of dis mediation isn't just a fat
direct to Consumers on a fat that
ultimately if you want someone to come
to your gym don't put some model up on
the ad put you up on the ad people
actually want to buy from other people
so one is I think consumers are voting
with their wallets to buy the directly
from the people behind it and even
larger Brands like you know with Fenty
it's right like like my favorite shirt
is is James purse and I think he makes
the best black t-shirts like J James
puts himself out there to the extent
that I feel like he cares more about
black tach than anybody else right
there's this there's this inherent
personal personalization and personality
to it that's the first thing the second
thing is we talked about this a bit
today
but there is no online versus offline
there is no Channel you sort of use a
great term I think you said uh
advertising agnostic it's ALS we're all
Channel agnostic now oh yeah like there
is no I buy a line I pick up in store it
is literally just about consumer choice
and if you think back you know 30 years
300 years I don't know maybe 3,000 years
how retail was done the retailer the the
the merchant dictated the consumer how
to buy if you want to buy bread at the
you know at a At This Town Square 300
years ago you go to the baker the baker
would say here's my hours of operation
here's how you pay wait in line here the
one major thing that is clear clear to
me through this is that things have been
flipped in their head now the consumer
is saying no no I'm going to purchase in
the most convenient way for me which
means I'm going to buy it online if I
want or Buy in Tik Tok or Instagram or
the online store buy a mobile app or buy
a Marketplace but I think if you have an
opportunity you're watching this right
now to sell across different channels
even though that's not what I'm I'm not
a physical retailer Ben Francis Jim
shark was not a physical retailer
they're an online retailer and they're
killing it in physical retail right now
because they don't give a [__] it
doesn't matter where you B and I swear
they don't care where you buy they care
that you buy they care you have a great
experience that is a future of retail
and one of the reasons that I think that
it's reflected here is because this is
like this is means that entrepreneurship
is becoming so democratized that
companies didn't exist five years ago
are now beating the [__] out of the
biggest companies in the world I don't
know how Macy is doing today I don't
know how Best Buy is doing today but I
assume they're not doing as well as
these people are doing because they
simply are are too removed from the
transaction from the value creation and
I think like your point like value first
right like soft ask give people more
than they expect and then eventually
they'll they'll give you what you
they'll give you their their hard
dollars so I'm GNA go I'm go super
historical because you said 3,000 years
Sor no it's good and so you think about
the Roman Empire right and so there was
this period of time before Shopify
before social media where a lot of
things got democratized by technology
right um where but what defeated the
Roman Empire it wasn't another massive
Empire it was lots of Barbarians
nibbling at the sides and then
eventually obviously no silver bullets
yeah hundreds of golden BB's that's
theame right and so the thing is is that
we as entrepreneurs represent those
golden BBS and so that market share is
these are gold BS literally literally is
that market share is up for grabs and
you can out the thing is it's like you
can always out compete so I'm just going
to draw here so it's like you're not
going to beat somebody at the world
right it's it's very tough to do that if
you're starting out but you can be the
absolute mayor of this tiny little duck
and say like in this world if if you if
you were an entrepreneur who uh likes
black t-shirts I am obsessed with black
t-shirts and people are like you know
what there's these other brands that I
like but I'm gonna black my I'm gonna
buy my black t-shirts from this guy
James James Pierce right and it's
because like well I'm sure they have
this whole catalog at for wori or
whatever but like this guy just loves
black I have a black T-shirt guy that's
all I want to wear that's exact and
actually so I just actually I pulled up
I want so uh the top trending products
right now across the world these are
millions of Stores um it is an Alpine
waffle beanie from viori it is a
two-piece pajam set from Little sleepies
it's a blanket from Lola blankets it's a
lip liner from Victoria Beckham it's a
peptide lip treatment I don't know what
that is from Road and it's hair Ser from
Olex these are not like other than viori
I haven't bought anything in any of
these stores yeah but there's a there's
a massive business called Lola blankets
that sells blankets and I'm willing to
bet given that they're trending right
now now across millions of stores they
probably really give a [__] about
blanket and I'm pretty sure that little
sleepies really cares about sleep wear
and pajamas so this idea of taking a
niche and blowing it up and inviting
more people to participate you can build
these multi-million dollar I mean or
billion dollar
companies in your Niche if you do that
one thing really really well and this is
where the Tam expands right and so you
you think about like okay well sleep
wear pajamas well the traditional person
would look at that be like well okay
what's the what's the number of pajamas
sold every year or sleepware that sold
every year and be like all right why
think I can capture 5% or 10% but the
thing is is like what we don't take into
consideration is like can I make
sleepware cooler than being naked yes
tough on that one but like can I make it
cooler than maybe a Mumu or a big
t-shirt or whatever and so it's like
okay that's what that's I'm I'm fighting
the couch I'm fighting sleep and I think
that's where these new categories can
emerge and then you can so quickly with
online now scale like to the Moon well I
was actually going to say that as well
so the percentage of crossb orders right
now is is getting to 20% Which is quite
remarkable because what that really
means is that in 2024 the businesses
that I admire the most they are default
Global now again if you run a gym in a
particular City that may be more
difficult I understand that but if you
were able to sell to a larger audience
let's say you're based in Las Vegas I
mean Canada's not that far that's where
I come from like it's a three-hour
flight there's 40 million people there
and the average household income is
pretty much the same as United States so
you have another 40 million people right
there yeah most shipping companies will
go there uh at least for now we have
free trade agreements so it's not that
difficult for you to ship there so this
idea of saying well I'm I'm a I'm a
us-based or I'm a Canadian based company
like the fact that jym shark is based in
the UK I think most people don't even
know that fact that Shopify is based in
Canada I assume most people don't know
that because it doesn't matter it's 2024
right we are all default Global and I
think that is also an amazing
opportunity that if it's working in this
geography it's very easy to expand if
you do it well and that is where this
little dot over here just starts just
starts being this little this little
this little dot that could right and
realistically what happens is it
actually grows outside of the original
town right is that there's whole other
group of people and maybe you capture
this little bit here that says you know
what this I do like their pajamas better
than someone else's but all these people
are like man I like this just better
than than whatever I was doing before I
I'll personalize it so um one of my best
friends in the world is a guy named
David seagull David seagull created a
company called David's te David T I met
David in 2015 he was taking David's Tea
public I was taking shop light public so
he he built a billion dollar I like he
took the company public it was an $800
million market cap company and it was I
think there were 350 David te retail
locations all over North America amazing
T entrepr he ends up leaving the company
and we're it's it's during the pandemic
we're sitting around I'm like what do
you want to do next he's like I don't
really know I'm thinking about doing
this or that I was like you're obsessed
with tea he's like yeah I know I was
like how you thought about doing
high-end tea like really great well cuz
I was like I drink I I drink tea but I
have no idea what I'm drinking right I'm
like green tea please or mint tea I'm
like what about teaching the world about
really highend tea great product exactly
right teach people about it and he's
like well the problem is we tried to do
the David's Tea and it was too it was
too highend it didn't work for that
audience David was a mass audience a lot
of flavors a lot of like you know like
tropical flavors very sweet and so
they're like it was too small of an
audience I was like but what if we do it
if if we just do it the two of us we
built this thing called Firebelly t.com
it's small company but we have one
particular demographic it's for people
that love high in and even though it's a
small little dot in a larger T Market
because we're the best of what we do in
that particular Market it's actually
real business it makes real money so I
think that there is like you may be
working in a company right now you I
don't I don't like this term but like
you know like entrepreneur an
entrepreneur working in a big company
and there may be something right now in
that company that you think is a great
idea but that compan is like it's too
small of an opportunity it's priority
seven and we're only the top three you
may be able to start that thing and it
may be big enough for you and 10 people
to work on together even though the
Fortune 500 thinks it's not that big of
a deal sure and I actually think that is
where those opportunities for
entrepreneurs are endless yeah those
crumbs on a uh on a hundred billion doll
Cookie prom on that cookies enough to
set you up for the rest of shop shop app
store right we have 13,000 apps in shop
Play App Store so if you're an
entrepreneur you're a merchant you can
find all these amazing apps and often
we're asked why don't we build it
ourselves well because we can't do that
we have millions stores we have to do
what most people need most of the time
so we leave room for people to build
their own companies and through that
clavo is a billion dollar company uh
aerm is a multi-billion dollar company
we partner with stripe companies that
were built on the ecosystem we actually
encourage them we want you to go build
because it's not something that we can
do because we're focused on like you
know transactions and check out and
Order and inventory and Order management
the bigger things we have to I think
those are huge opportunities and that's
all collaboration I'll just say that
because I know Harley off camera too and
like he collaboration is like in his
bloodline totally um it's like I mean
he's probably the most gregarious guy
I've met like like if I if I like needed
to connect with like the president of
Zimbabwe I'd probably text you first be
like oh yeah so I don't know his name
I'm GNA mess something up but um I don't
know the president of Zimbabwe I'm sure
he's a great person and I think he
should be an entrepreneur as well yeah I
think he should start some sort of
Zimbabwe you know butcher box you know
company Bark Box type company and I'll
bring this I I think I'll bring this on
here but the the list of items that
Harley just read as the top the top
selling items that are happening across
all of Shopify so number one everything
that we just went is from the the
horse's mouth the man who yeah you're
hearing it first now I did like I did
CNN I did like ABC I did CBS like I
didn't mention some of these on there
like this is this is for you and your
community you were my people I am an
entrepreneur like all of you and so but
this is from pulling back the curtain of
the things that these guys are doing it
and Harley knows the the CMOS and the
CEOs of each of these companies and got
to I'm sure participate in some of these
conversations that led to uh led to the
creation I remember when some of these
these companies were getting started
their mom's kitchen table and they a lot
of them had the same question I'm sure
you all you all had I think the
difference is that one like the head I
mean if you're an entrepreneur you got
to be you pers right like you know I I I
always described as like like they're
two types of people big Title Wave is
coming and you have the people that run
for the towels on the shore and you have
the people that go get the surfboard
yeah and like uh you know entrepreneurs
are the surfboard people yeah and
they're the ones that build these
massive global companies think it's like
a golden age of Entrepreneurship you
know one thing we didn't talk about we
talked about opportunity but also the
cost of failure right now it's about as
low as it's ever been so in terms of
your you know 100 or 1,000 BBS you can
throw out those BBS because if one
doesn't work it doesn't mean you're
going to lose your house so I I give
this analogy of the lottery ticket which
is like every entrepreneur has this like
ultimate stack of lottery tickets and so
you can scratch them off and cash them
in and the thing is is that if you lose
you're back at the exact same position
you are at so you have basically
unlimited shots on goal right now for
the cost of probably a sub you know a
software subscription and if you compare
this to the the bakery that you uh have
to start you know in 1930 where you have
to work for 10 years put up half the
money yourself sign away everything so
that if for some reason the bakery
doesn't work that's it for you that's it
for life you'll never have a loan again
you'll never yeah that's that's that's
that's all you get and so it's like we
have so many more shots on goal that the
difficulty is so what's the what's the
what's the competition for
entrepreneurship it's distraction it's
your phone it's it's it's never been
easier to be successful and it's also
never been easier to be distractive it's
also hard like you know um I'm Canadian
so I don't celebrate us Thanksgiving we
have Thanksgiving another time but I
suspect last night a bunch of you were
sitting around your your dinner table
with your family and they're like you
know they're going around the table and
you got like cousin David who's a doctor
and you got like you know cousin
Jennifer who's a CPA she's an accountant
she works at you know some big
accounting firm and they get to you like
what are you do you're like oh I'm an
entrepreneur they're like oh like how's
the Tik Tok guys right exactly so like I
I have felt like that my entire life it
was I I kid you not we I've been at shop
now for almost 16 years I'm 40 so more
than the third of my life and I think it
was only around like the IPO maybe a
year after the IPO that my mom and dad
were like okay like now I realized why
you'd become legit you are legit so like
I feel that too um because it is a
little lonely totally right I mean
entrepreneurship has a lot of perks and
a lot of wonderful benefits but it's
also qu quite lonely and unlike I think
our our parents and grandparents
Generations it's not celebrated like it
is now usually people went into
entrepreneurship there's this term
called forced entrepreneurship that's
why most people did for like most people
became entrepreneurs in the in the like
30s 40s 50s and 60s because they had no
other choices we are now choosing to be
entrepreneurs because we're deeply
passionate people who really give a [__]
want to build cool stuff the older
Generations don't understand it as as
well I think and I think the the the
point you made about legitimacy is
something that I I'll just I'll just
make my quick statement which is um for
everybody who's watching this that that
is a struggle that all entrepreneurs go
to at at every level and so some people
call it impostor syndrome I I've never
really resonated with that that term but
the idea that you're like no one thinks
I'm Legit right but fundamentally if you
have a product and you sell it and
customers are happy and you exchange
goods and services for money you own a
business period as long as you're you
know abiding by the law right guess you
could have an IL legal business but as
far as far as I'm concerned I'm
encouraging you know legal
entrepreneurship um that's it that's
legitimacy and if someone has a problem
with you doing that [__]
them the snide comments at the at the
thing oh yeah he's got his little te
thing how's that going little guy but
the thing is is that no one everyone
thinks about today not forever and so
like Shopify is celebrating their 10th
year but like 10 years as much as that's
a long time it also isn't that long to
go from what did you guys IPO at a
billion a billion so going from a
billion to 150 billion in 10 years right
and so uh I think I mean Microsoft was I
think seven years from from inception to
to their IPO and was a you know it took
it took us 10 years to get to the
billion from right like we were
snowboard shop yeah that we were a
snowboard shop in Ottawa Canada above a
a buffet restaurant right and there's
this and the thing is is there's this as
you said endurance right there's this
perseverance that has to kick in
basically business is an infinite game
and the only way that you lose is that
you give up and so many of the
permutations of the biggest companies in
the world right now started as as surf
jop slack started as something
completely different than gam company
right completely different and so your
first business won't be your last
business it's very unlikely that you're
Zuckerberg or your BOS most most people
have like I have nine nine failures
before my first real big one and so like
it's just part of the game I know you
did t-shirts you did DJ I've done so
many other things have not worked out
you know the one thing that you and I
have to do better and and maybe maybe we
should do this maybe you do this better
than I do but I often will talk about
the Highland reel I don't talk about the
bloopers right I talk a lot about
t-shirts and DJs DJ which went well for
Shopify of course but I don't talk about
I had a slipper company I had a poker
chip company I had a bunch of stuff that
that that failed miserably um but I
didn't like this idea that that you can
just like have that endurance that the
next one has the same motivation as the
previous one I think works really well
and like we are literally looking at
like I pray at the altar of
Entrepreneurship and these this is the
result of Entrepreneurship you know $2.8
million every single minute this is not
coming from like you know this is the
longtail shop ofice stor that are
generating that are sell to 30 million
unique shoers 30 million that's almost
that's almost the population in the
entire country of Canada where I come
from and soil itself I think being able
to separate failure from being a failure
so basically failing from being a
failure and so like failing actually
makes you more likely to be successful
than not because you don't take any
shots right and so it's just making sure
that you make that shift um and whether
it's also at the higher level whether
it's a new product line I mean like we
talk about specific businesses but there
have been products or features that you
rolled out like oh that was shiing we we
shop F we bought a company for you know
for over a billion dollars and ended up
selling it for for you know like because
we didn't we needed to get out of it it
was it didn't make sense for us we were
we sort of called these things like main
quest and side quests and we felt that
shipping was a side quest and eventually
we said we let to go back to our M Quest
and so we still make a lot of mistakes
but the key is that I'm not make not
make that mistake twice and I think you
also have to read sort of the the teager
in the environment like right now if
you're a publicly traded company there
is no room I think frankly generally if
you're a company at any scale whatsoever
there's no room for growth at all costs
right like you like you want to grow a
business properly but you also want to
show that you can be profitable um so
like now a couple years ago maybe that
was different but I I think you sort of
have to react to like what the macro
environment dictates from um but more
importantly I think entrepreneurship is
the greatest thing in the world I think
it's the greatest way for humans to self
self-actualize I think it it creates it
allows people to find their own
definition of success whatever that
might be and doesn't matter what your
last name is or who your father like my
father you know is not anyone who would
ever know he was a failed entrepreneur
he a wonderful man he supported me but
he was never able to help me financially
and it doesn't make a difference because
the value that I am my value as an
entrepreneur is how much value I create
not who I am and that's sort of where I
think entrepreneurship is like this
great equalizer yeah it's all based on
performance all performance doesn't
matter Nothing Else Matters which
personally is something that I've always
been very attracted to which is like you
don't have it's not based on your
ability to to to kiss the boss's ass no
exactly like how good are you right one
more thing this is this is this is how
this is how I like to think things all
right so we're going to do a Rapid Fire
recap of the tactics that we talk we're
have to take off my shirt sort of like
yeah we're going to do it we're going to
strip down it's it's strip tactics okay
so right off the bat we have um this a
mess hold on we started here I think
right was gym
shark yeah okay here we go so gym shark
number one so uh they had an offline
present so this was big I'll put a
little check mark here okay so online
company offline presents yes uh they wo
in these little Easter eggs into their
marketing to get their uh Their audience
and their fans excited about their
marketing like literally excited about
the product and it was like a bit of a
secret right it was like an Open Secret
of like what what are they going to do
next yes exactly now also in terms of
products they weren't trying to sell
everything they were trying to be more
focused on the few products that were
going to drive the most Revenue that
they because they did a 12we popup
probably already knew and will know from
next for next year what they're going to
do next and crush it yeah I I love it I
mean can you imagine the meeting where
they're like What's So holiday popup
great how longone like let's do it for
three months and they're like it's a
holiday popup they're like do it for
three months and they did it I think
they're winning it's a long like a
crispy crispy popup I what um also just
making sure that the sites that you have
during the seasons where people have
their credit card out are optimized for
conversion so like there is a time for
Branding there is a time for making an
ask and when the when the going is good
go hard now uh we covered the pre-test
winner so I'm going to I'm to we're
going to go to what do we got we got
Bark Box okay so Bark Box did this great
great thing which I think every B I mean
I'm a huge huge this is a star one for
me quizzes challenges in-depth data
collection so that you can personalize a
discount or personalize an experience I
think makes it just it just it you get
data they get something back in return
everybody wins and then you get all the
remarketing on the back end it's just
like a super super if you want to see
who does challenge based Commerce better
than anyone on the planet it's a company
called Mischief you heard of Mischief I
believe it's spelled like this yeah yeah
okay okay Mischief so Mischief does
these crazy things where they'll say
there is a PT Cruiser remember the PT
Cruiser there's a PT Cruiser in this
block radius with the door unlocked and
the keys in the ignition if you can find
it you get to keep the PT Cruiser and
they do these crazy Subs all the time
but they are the masters of creating
these like these gamification and if
you're interested in this particular
topic go study mischief and so if you're
like okay where does that fit in my
marketing strategy so when we were
talking about the new balance of the 70%
this is basically delayed Ras is that
you're putting this money in saying okay
well instead ofing spending you know
again this is scale here but let's say
you spend a million dollar a month in
advertising if you say you know what
we're going to spend 50 Grand on this
car and we're going to give it away you
will probably get more than just
spending 5% more on your ads right so
there's this point where you get these
trade-offs we having the story and the
emotional connection Etc is is Big Time
um I like highlighting this which is if
if you have when the going is good make
sure that you've got something where
first-time buyers know what to get now
most of these stores had like a keystone
offer that they had either it was line
with their banner and even on the on the
bottom left for desktop where it was
just like hey this is the like start
here go here um I love directing I mean
every every everything that I put on my
site says start here like just this is
where you start leave the breadcrumbs
leave them down the road you want them
to take yeah yeah so common theme here
obviously prioritize best products
making sure that you have urgency in the
banner these are super uh super tactical
things and authorized for the date it
doesn't not every day is Black Friday I
get that but there are particular days
like you know like New Year's is a day
Christmas is a day boxing day whatever
it is like there are partic Halloween
there are particular days where you can
simply just add a very simple new theme
or skin your site to make it to make it
so it's so timely that you know you need
to check out right now because tomorrow
you know it's going to be totally
different I can virtually guarantee you
that if you put a seasonal rapper so in
the offers book the last chapter is
about the wrapping paper with like how
do you change your offer on a consistent
basis without changing your business
right and so my my theme Here is become
a fraternity party player right like if
Tom gets his his tooth pulled out it's
like Ker wisdom teeth right like you it
doesn't matter what the reason why is
just that you have a reason so that you
can have your promotion and so it could
be your daughter's birthday it could be
your anniversary of your wedding it
doesn't matter uh as long as you say hey
I'm celebrating my anniversary and
because of that everything that's
couples related boom and you can get
that information through these
challenges right and this is why this is
like a super high leverage all right
boom so next one is
QVC this is low low tech means high tech
Okay so oh this one I like because on
the video Dem man like QVC this is to me
a story of creating the least amount of
friction even though QVC has done
something for decades a particular Way
new technology came out they made it
less like again this is concurrent video
you don't have to leave the video to buy
you can buy write them there through a
thumbnail they are if if they can change
their way after 50 years because new
technology made it easier everyone else
can can do that I think it's amazing and
so I'm just say like what's the
fundamental of this it's frictionless
yeah right it's dreamline it's it's
meeting the customer where they're at
and every single every business can take
one step towards your customer what is
crazy is that when you take one step
it's an order of magnitude Improvement
in terms of conversions um BK Beauty I
mean this is like you know like you
don't have to compete with the biggest
companies if you want to you can but
also there's T like some of these big
companies I kid you not you're sitting
up you're watching this right now they
they are scared of you and so rather
than you going ahead and and competing
with them they got a big budgets some of
them are worth comp collaborating with
not competing with you may actually
create something amazing they're going
to love it maybe they can pay for your
ad budget and you just made you made
yourself less of a risk to them and you
can sell more product and this is coming
from somebody who's in these boardrooms
who's talking to these big Brands so I
want there to be like credibility behind
what car no this is real the biggest
brands on the planet are scared of not
their their exact competition they're
scared of two people in a garage yeah
who's going to be the next the next guy
to defr them all right so we got Burger
Kake so uh having the Advent calendar
the promo calendar I can't believe we
have Burger King on it's awesome awesome
yeah and so uh they you know obviously
they were cheeky with their their
marketing they're like almost cool now
which where like I don't want to say
like I think they're almost cool um and
using their Advent calter to test I mean
this is this emphasis that we talk about
gym shark U obviously Burger King did it
but I think this is like it's it's a
it's a it's a multi- dip right like I I
love talking about like how can I get
double dip or triple dip or quadruple
dip on a one move that I make and so
this gets lots of PR it gets lots of
earned media it gets lots of shares lots
of people paying attention it generates
sales it allows you to reward the most
hardcore fans and it allows you to
collect data so that next year you have
a a huge advantage over your competition
or at least what you would have done if
you didn't have the data to sell more
product y love it all right and then
butcher box I mean this is sort of this
is like this is you this is like like
like this is totally it is all about
giving give more value provide more
value to them that you capture for
yourselves and do that over and over
again until you're ready to say now it's
time for us to share in this upside but
this idea of creating classes with no
call to action no sales pitch just
here's an amazing class here's another
amazing class oh by the way this next
class if you want to buy if you want to
cook like simultaneously here's here's a
link to actually buy the ingredients it
just creates this different Rel it
doesn't feel like you're being sold
to I mean this has been my entire
marketing strategy and so I'm I'm like
I'm super privy to this and the thing
that I will I will highlight and that I
want to push back on because there's I
can hear I can hear the comments saying
well must be nice right of well how how
they they could acquire something like
that right like they can do that but or
or this doesn't apply to my business as
an accountant or this doesn't apply to
my business as a whatever literally so
this is my this is Alex's Pro my my true
cents on this is that marketing and
sales are one Continuum first off all
right so they're not like these two
separate functions just because of have
different people do them does not mean
that the actual psychological process is
different and as far as I'm concerned
all of that acquisition process is a
process of education and so all we're so
if we Define education as
uh a change of behavior with under the
same conditions so if same conditions
new Behavior someone has learned we have
educated and so the point of marketing
is to change their behavior under the
same conditions of what we of what we
put out and so if somebody comes in as a
regular T user and then all of a sudden
finds out that these te's contain some
things that aren't as good and these
te's are much better they digest better
they they're more cognitive clear
they're deeper taste whatever then all
of a sudden you you move you're like oh
I'm no longer a normal teego or I'm
actually I kind of do like these higher
you mentioned accountants for example I
assume that's one of one of the greatest
examples because the tax code changes
fairly rapidly in most countries even in
the US right if you put every time the
tax code change if you put in a 60c
video that says here's everything you
need to know about section
8722 this new change 60 seconds and you
do it again and again if someone is
looking for a new accountant yeah
they're like who do I actually go to
take advice from most oh yeah it's this
person on YouTube who whats up these
great 60-second videos I'm going to see
if he's available or she's available
he's obsessed with black t-shirts right
like he's obsessed with the tax and
specifically okay so we're thinking
about C so we'll just let's use this
give me the overhead so if this is
you're like well I'm not going to
compete with PWC or ey or some of the
big County it's like yeah but but all we
got to do is beat them with plumbers and
E by the they are never e all those big
firms they're never going to be able to
do a 60-second video that's organic like
that it'll have to compliance and
committees and all that you can out
compete them because you can go faster
it's amazing and so uh with this this is
the back Black Friday wrapup from behind
the scenes from the man of the myth the
legend the president of Shopify Harley
thanks so much for coming up manate so
much fun and uh thank you all for
joining us this was unhinged and
wonderful so me at least appreciate you
guys rock and roll enjoy the weekend
enjoy the holidays get back to work